you know I've thought so much I didn't
realize it would be so difficult to try
and think what is it about Vanessa mom
you know her earlier roles charge of the
Light Brigade Mary Queen of Scots
Isadora
I mean FIFA sizes staggering beauty and
as Ray said sensuality um I think it's
sort of a purity of spirit that the very
rarely seen as though sitting in the
audience you can actually feel her skin
pulsating or as Martin Sherman said you
can feel the heat coming off her skin or
my father described it as her emotional
flow her total commitment and when I
finally got to work with mom I realized
that she was more present in her work
than she often is in real life and I
thought ah that's where she lives
you know I'm another quality that I feel
she has um my opinion is is that she
sort of seems to break this invisible
barrier between audience member and
celluloid um I got an email last week
from a friend it said searing
performance about Vanessa and Rafe's
film Coriolanus you know it just the
truth seers and actually there's a
moment in Camelot which mom you didn't
tell this story so it is just a little
family thing that actually you said how
much you loved it but that actually when
you were offered it you didn't want to
do it and you turned it down you wanted
to carry on making films like Morgan and
blow up and it was my father that said
no Vanessa you're going to do Camelot
and you know when I watch it there's a
moment in that talking about searing
truth is that within the background of
this huge 60s a musical as we saw Arthur
and Guinevere saying goodbye to each
other
and Guinevere's off to a nunnery and she
says that it in the past she's looked in
his face for forgiveness and hopes that
she will see it again but that she won't
be there to see it and it's really
heartbreaking you know again one of
those moments and that is all about
truth then funnily enough I asked mom
about if she ever thought of an
alternative career what that might be
and and she said a nun
before science pushed her in another
direction but you know still what is it
what is the power of mum when she's at
her very best and you know she does
extensive research I'm placing the
character and historical context and
very Stanislavski based but you know
what whereas I feel most of us may be
speaking for myself as actors unirii
draw an observation psychological makeup
and intent when I look at mom's work
it's as though she's drawing on the
elements you know she taps into this
this thing that you know it was called
Jung's collective unconscious so that so
that when we see her weep as a character
it's not it's not just the character
sadness we feel but as Ray said a sort
of universal sadness and similarly my
daughter Daisy and Vanessa's eldest
grandchild went to a music festival
Coachella last summer and at the end
that the hot ticket this band Arcade
Fire got up to play and suddenly as
their backdrop
they had Vanessa in that clip we saw
earlier singing it's May it's May and so
50 years on I feel the power of that
clip is that she can somehow embody this
collective joy the critic Bernhard Levin
wrote of you as Rosalind quoting
Shakespeare and echoed in my father's
autobiography and Toni continued and at
the center of it was this great golden
flame so light so fluid so involving it
made me think mum of what you said to me
that you quoted Ellen Terry that all you
ever wanted to be was a useful actress
and I think we will agree you're very
useful
you